I used to not understand I'm like why
would a man not fight for his kid and
then I realized a lot of these guys that
are homeless have just been like wrecked
in the court system she could ring her
lawyer up every day for a month and
every single phone call every single
letter goes on his bill but if she takes
him to court and bleeds him dry and
leaves him penniless she then gets the
counsel out she is incentivized to
bankrupt and they'll kick the man out of
the house with the man's name on the
mortgage so they're still paying their
mortgage in a house they're kicked out
of and I'm like would you fight in court
if you would a 10 chance of winning you
either settle out of court for an
extortionate amount of money or go to
court and pay double that meanwhile
there is no risk on the woman's side at
all it's the most sexist thing I've ever
seen in my life like the kid really
isn't yours it's really hers legally and
I understand that women obviously like
make the decision to give life but we've
got no rights
the true Geordie podcast